bremerhaven wir schauen auf dieses video
ein wandel sitzt neben einer ampel an
einer straßenecke und neben ihm da sehen
sie es liegt ein gegenstand der nach
einer armbrust aussieht und plötzlich
legt er sich auf den boden verschränkte
die hände auf dem rücken und die
passanten laufen zunächst teilnahmslos
an diesem manne vorbei
war ein fußgänger der bleibt stehen ich
habe sie hier und schiebt den gegenstand
weg das ist jörg damage und hält damit
ihm gesprochen er sah bei geöffnetem
fenster aus dem büro und sei so sagt er
der typ der da um sich schoss jetzt
rasend polizeifahrzeuge an beamte nahmen
den mann fest
lässig gibt er die waffe des
mutmaßlichen amokläufers von bremerhaven
zur seite damit verhindert ja der mich
vielleicht schlimmeres aber sicher
beweis der mutter mit davon
damit aufgehört wenn ich über die straße
gehen damit klare ansage gemacht was er
machen soll und habe die waffen an die
seite geschoben damit er da nicht mehr
drauf
der mutmaßliche täter liegt derweil auf
der straße lässt sich augenscheinlich
ohne gegenwehr von der polizei
festnehmen neben ihm die armbrust auf
dem video nicht zu sehen der mutmaßliche
täter feuert mindestens sieben
stahlpfeiler aus der armbrust ab einige
hinterlassen gut sichtbare löcher in den
fassaden und plötzlich zieht er eine
weitere waffe
und hat dann eine handfeuerwaffe die
pistole aus der tasche gezogen
die aber wohl nicht funktioniert hat
versucht zu schiessen aber leider
irgendwie irgendwas bringen 10 die sich
unweit des lloyd gymnasiums abspielen wo
der mutmaßliche täter zuvor nach bild
-informationen eine sekretärin verletzt
und rund 200 schüler in todesangst
versetzt
stunden lang müssen die schüler in ihren
klassenräumen ausharren erst nachdem die
polizei das schulgebäude durchsucht
hatte werden die schüler aus dem gebäude
eskortiert nach unseren informationen
soll der mutmaßliche täter akzentfrei
deutsch gesprochen haben und sich im
alter eines abiturienten befinden im
moment laufen noch die ermittlungen zum
täter der sich in unserem gewahrsam
befindet und sobald es dann neuerungen
gibt können wir dazu auch stellen kürzen
vor genau einer woche verhindert die
polizei einen amoklauf an einem essener
gymnasium ein 16 jähriger wollte dort
offenbar mit rohrbomben ein blutbad
anrichten
erschreckend ist die zahl der versuchten
und vereitelten amokläufe in den letzten
tagen die motive der täter oft unklar
fest steht die polizei kommt ihnen immer
häufiger per social media auf die
schliche zum glück noch vor ihren tagen
[Musik]